[Música]
quisiera compartir una reflexión sobre
lo que puede significar una cultura
colectivista en un momento como éste en
el que el mundo está viviendo una
pandemia
yo no soy médica mi mamá es japonesa y
además en mi trabajo de muchos años he
tenido contacto con cuestiones
literarias sociológicas y antropológicas
de la cultura japonesa y creo que
ciertos comportamientos y respuestas
sociales e individuales de la sociedad
japonesa pueden servirnos a la hora de
afrontar una crisis como esta
vale hacernos una primera pregunta
porque japón pudo evitar mayor impacto
del contagio si ya en enero se dio el
primer caso estando tan cerca de china
teniendo casi 130 millones de habitantes
en muy reducido espacio teniendo de las
poblaciones de tercera edad mayores del
mundo
siendo el segundo país con más fumadores
por cantidad de habitantes porque en
japón la infección de este virus no ha
tenido un crecimiento exponencial sino
un avance lineal identificado hasta
ahora
sabemos que este nuevo corona virus es
muy contagioso en estos datos
demográficos entonces japón nos presenta
un cóctel que permitiría una gran
propagación de la enfermedad
básicamente muchísima gente en poco
lugar y un cuarto de esa gente con más
de 65
qué pasa entonces la japonesa es una
sociedad educada de tal manera que
responde de forma orgánica y unida ante
cualquier evento que la comprometa
japón pasó por guerras tifones sonami
japón recibe 1500 terremotos por año
y temblores por día generación tras
generación ha tenido que sobrellevar
catástrofes naturales o generadas por el
hombre
esto lo podemos pensar con algo que les
gusta mucho a los argentinos equipos de
fútbol como ejemplo
que el equipo de fútbol va a tener mejor
performance ante un momento crítico
el equipo que entrena todos los días
tiene infraestructura en el que cada uno
sabe que tiene que hacer o el equipo que
nunca entreno que no tiene
infraestructura y que tiene que salir a
improvisar
las directivas de distanciamiento social
higiene y comportamiento individual sea
en sociedad o en la casa propia la
población japonesa no tiene establecido
de hace cientos de años
no hace falta decir no abrazarse no
darse besos porque no lo hacen se
saludan con una reverencia
dar distancia es un gesto de respeto y
la mayoría de los trabajadores en
lugares públicos usan guantes
no hace falta recomendar sacarse los
zapatos al entrar a la casa porque ya es
costumbre
no hay que indicar no estornudar ni
toser sobre otra persona porque esto es
un protocolo habitual entre los
japoneses de hecho estudios de hace años
muestran que más del 50 por ciento de
japoneses usarán barbijo al sentirse
resfriado no para proteger a sí mismo
sino para proteger al otro
aquí va el mensaje fundamental de una
cultura colectivista el bien del todo es
más importante que el bien de una parte
para ilustrar esto me gustaría cerrar
con una experiencia que hicieron dos
maestros occidentales en un colegio en
japón
seguramente conocerán el juego de las
sillas se pone música sillas en un
círculo una menos que la cantidad de
participantes y se van sacando de a una
en cada ronda
se hizo esta experiencia en japón y los
chicos en vez de empujarse para tomar
una silla quedaron todos cediendo el
lugar a un compañero porque da vergüenza
ganar uno cuando otro sufre
la palabra japonesa ama e expresa esta
manera de ser se trata de tener la
confianza de que el otro me va a cuidar
en resonancia consentir que nos
realizamos cuando cuidamos de otros
en el ejemplo hay niños pero ya podemos
ver cómo funciona una sociedad
colectivista se ayuda a sí misma porque
cada individuo contribuye al bien de
todos
[Aplausos]